we've seen everyone from uh politicians
in the united states and internationally
we've seen uh the cftc the sec the occ
uh a whole bunch of alphabet soup
organizations i didn't even know existed
that are all weighing in with their
opinions on various parts of the
industry what's your read on the
regulatory uh situation and kind of the
rule set uh both in the u.s and
internationally
firstly the reason you hear from all
those agencies is there's a fight going
on to who's regulated right is it a
commodity is it a currency is it a
security right so that's clear that
they've got a [ __ ] fight going on
genzo's flexing his muscles and being
the loudest about it meanwhile you get
these snarky comments from the others
like it's not all down to him so that
has to be decided so basically what we
have to do is decide how to do this
so against us making his play he's
saying well everything's a security
fine
if you want to define it that way that's
okay too
security doesn't make it illegal or a
terrible thing i mean apple's a security
and so it's a us treasury so that's okay
but what you're gonna have to do
is change what securities laws what that
means because if you are gonna stop the
pace of development and innovation
you're going to shoot yourself in the
foot and it will be
arbitraged away by going to different
jurisdictions
so the u.s is hampered by this
ridiculous 1934 securities law
um and the howie test so people use that
as the big thing see it's a security
it's like but that doesn't mean there's
criminal activity it means how you issue
something and who's allowed to buy it is
somewhat restricted now is that the
right thing to do is this what the world
should
should be doing should we be restricting
young people with less savings from this
new exciting technology or not my view
is we should not much like we shouldn't
stop them investing in startups we
should give them warnings we should give
them understanding some education about
what they're doing but people need to be
allowed to do this
because they're allowed to go to vegas
they're allowed to throw all of their
pay in all of their life savings and
nobody gives a [ __ ] zero regulations
they can lend it to their uncle who
steals it no regulations but heaven
forbid if you buy something that's
listed as a security you know the
ridiculous laws around um accredited
investors it's just morally wrong and it
doesn't stand up so i think this is the
battle that's going to get fought
i think the battle is gensler is laying
out the hard case everything's security
we're going to start prosecuting people
and then we'll figure it out and i think
the industry is going to coalesce along
with um voters we're going to coalesce
around
yeah but if you turn it into the the um
securities industry that we grew up with
we're not going to accept it and so
there's going to be a fight
and that fight will lead to a grand
compromise and that grand compromise was
exactly what happened to the internet
regulation and mo and phone regulations
beforehand
it will come
but it won't be easy so my guess is the
you know if we do have another bear
market phase
that comes in somewhere in 2022 um i
think it starts later
2022 2023 it's all going to be about the
fight of regulation and that mixed
signal that's going to keep people away
from the space and it's going to push
innovation to countries where it's
clearer such as south korea or singapore
classic negotiation skills that always
start with a hard line because it gives
you the upper hand because what you're
trying to do is there's the middle line
you're trying to get it incrementally
over the middle line further in your
direction and guenzo wants that and our
job is to get it somewhere across the
other side and the answer is going to be
somewhere in the middle let's see who
wins and think about what happens if if
what i think is going to happen is this
2 trillion is maybe 10 trillion by let's
say march of next year what are you
going to do then
what are you going to do with the nfts
what are you going to do with these
social tokens what are you going to do
with d5
you you cannot go back find a bunch of
people say you were naughty
who's the voice of god here who knows
what d5 protocol is going to survive and
which one is what some some guy in the
sec goes this is a a good project and
that's a bad
no the market makes that decision that
is the job of the market you just have
to warn people what risks they're taking
you know people have to
have to be allowed to take risk now
you're seeing the younger generation
taking more risk than was traditional
for us
and the reason being is options
robin hood and they're like [ __ ] it i've
got my one chance and they're taking
more risk that's good there's nothing
wrong with risk taking just as long as
people understand options are great
because you can only lose what you put
in now if you put in your life savings
that's a pretty stupid thing but you see
it on wall street bets that they kind of
acknowledge that
and they laugh about their losses but
what you're doing is mass educating all
of these people about risk taking and i
think they're going to be larger
risk-takers
than our generation the gen x's were or
the um particularly the baby boomers
that were much less risk-takers the
other piece of it too i think is uh
they're going further and further out on
the risk curve because they have to
right there's only correct there's only
so many assets they can buy that
actually have a real rate of return and
so naturally what do you do is if i
can't buy bonds well there goes 40 of
the traditional portfolio so what do i
do with that money do i put it in stocks
well you know some stocks are doing well
some aren't and you just kind of
continue to move out and then there are
digital uh natives and so naturally it
makes sense that they end up in uh in
bitcoin you know encrypted and they have
an informational advantage
so good on them right because i'm the
idiot who's trying to figure it out but
these guys have been born in that world
of course they don't have to figure
anything out it's just normal